[Musique]
l'instant d'une journée le quartier
général des efforts anti russe s'est
déplacé en pologne
le président américain est venu rassurer
un allié-clef
dubaï de souligner que la pologne prend
de très grandes responsabilités qui
devraient être partagés entre alliés il
est notamment question des centaines de
milliers d'ukrainiens accueilli par le
voisin polonais le président est allé à
la rencontre du crânienne qui ont fui en
laissant des frères ou des conjoints
derrière là bas il s'est assuré que
personne ne doutait de ses véritables
sentiments le brocciu joe biden comparé
bladimir poutine un boucher après
l'avoir traité de criminel de guerre et
de voyous des mots durs mais l'ukraine
réclame davantage
le ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères espère que les états unis
sauront convaincre l'europe de punir
davantage la russie une demande à
laquelle joe biden a fait écho dans une
discours inspiré de la lutte des pays
d'europe de l'est contre l'union
soviétique
il réclame que l'europe brise rapidement
sa dépendance aux énergies russe joe
biden a répété que les troupes de l'otan
n'irait pas affronter les russes en
ukraine
oh bah
oui c'est grave
mais il a été ferme l'alliance ferait
tout pour défendre chaque pouce carré de
son territoire une posture agressive un
président qui semble certain être du bon
côté de l'histoire
catch un jeu maintenant l'humain par
pour l'amour de dieu un pleur joe biden
l'a dit mir poutine ne plus rester au
pouvoir joe biden a lancé au peuple
russe qu'il ne méritait pas la guerre et
toutes ses conséquences économiques
entre les lignes il semble leur demander
de stopper leur président reste à savoir
si les russes ont même entendu le
message ici en exhumant baron
radio-canada varsovie